so a conditional statement is an if-then
statement okay so if blank then blank
right so if the hypothesis then the
conclusion right and we can think about
this and this might help you when you're
memorizing these different statements a
kind of abbreviated here so if P then Q
you can think of the arrow as like then
so if P that's the hypothesis then Q the
conclusion now what the converse is when
I think of the word converse I think of
in Reverse okay so you're basically
singing it backwards you're saying if Q
then P right so you're actually
reversing or interchanging the
hypothesis and the conclusion so it's
like saying it in Reverse the converse
now just because the conditional is true
doesn't necessarily mean that the
converse will be true okay so that's
something to pay attention to now with
the inverse the inverse you keep the
hypothesis and the conclusion in their
same spot right if P then Q but what
you're doing this little symbol here is
you're negating the hypothesis and
conclusion you're saying not P then not
Q okay so when you add that word not in
there you're making it that the opposite
you're basically negating it and then
the contrapositive what you do with the
contrapositive is you actually
interchange
okay the hypothesis and the conclusion
and you're negating both the hypothesis
and the conclusion so this reads like
this if not Q then not P now the thing
to remember and this will be helpful for
you is that the conditional and the
contrapositive they have the same truth
value which basically means that the
conditional is true the contrapositive
will also be true the conditional is
false the contrapositive statement will
also be false so they have the same
truth value same thing with the converse
and the inverse okay they have the same
truth value they're both true or they're
both false you can't have one be true
and the other one you know be false and
then the last one here the by
conditional statements you can see I
have a double arrow here and what that
means is that if P then Q is true Q then
P will also be true so it means it's
true forwards and backwards so usually
when we think of the arrow we think it
only flows in the direction of the arrow
so if P then Q but this is saying that
if Q is true then P will also be true
and the way we read this is we say P if
and only if Q so that if and only if
indicates to us sometimes abbreviated
with iff okay indicates to us that it's
true forwards and backwards it's a by
conditional statement let's get into
some examples and we'll talk about how
to work with each of these so if you
study then you will get a good grade so
whatever comes after the if that's our
hypothesis so you study then whatever
comes after the then that's your
conclusion you'll get a good grade so in
our diagram here if P then Q that's our
conditional statement okay so if you
study then you'll get a good grade what
would the converse be okay can you
figure that out the converse is going to
be going in reverse if you get a good
grade then you studied but that's not
necessarily true right you could have
gotten a good grade because the teacher
made the test really easy or maybe
you're just naturally great at math or
you know one of those kinds of things
now what about the inverse what we do
with the inverse is we add the word not
in there that's what negates okay
both the hypothesis and the conclusion
so we're going to say if you do not
study then you will not get a good grade
now notice we kept the hypothesis and
occlusion conclusion in the same order
right all we did was we negated them
okay now what about the contrapositive
now this sometimes gets a little bit
tricky but what you're going to be doing
it's a combination of the converse and
the inverse here's going to be switching
the hypothesis in the conclusion and
you're gonna be negating them so if we
read this is going to be if you do not
get a good grade then you did not study
and that's true if the conditional the
original statement is true okay so
you're with me so far let's go on to
another example if two angles this is a
math example so if two angles form a
linear pair then they are supplementary
so what's the linear pair well linear
just means line right and pair means two
so if you have two angles and they form
a line then they're supplementary what
supplementary mean it means that they
add up to 180 right so if two angles
form a linear pair then they're
supplementary that's true right okay
what would be the converse of this
statement if two angles are
supplementary then they form a linear
pair is that true well that's not
necessarily true because you could have
an angle over here okay and an angle
over here and you can see that they're
not forming a line they're not adjacent
to each other okay they're not sharing a
vertex and array so they're not forming
a line they're not a linear pair so
that's an example of the converse error
so just because you say something in
Reverse that doesn't mean it's true just
because it's true you know forward as a
conditional statement okay let's talk
about the inverse if two angles do not
form a linear pair then they are not
supplementary is that true or false
that's false right and the reason it's
false is because just because they don't
form a linear pair like these don't form
a linear pair doesn't mean that they're
not supplementary they could still add
up to 180 this could be a hundred and
twenty degrees and this could be sixty
degrees right okay how about the
contrapositive contrapositive we're
gonna switch the hypothesis and the
conclusion and we're going to negate
them both right so if two angles are not
supplementary right then they do not
form a linear pair now that's true
because if they're not supplementary
that means that they don't add up to
hundred eighty degrees there's no way
that they could be forming a straight
line okay a linear pair plus we know
from what we talked about earlier if the
conditionals true the contrapositive
will automatically be true they have the
same truth value or if this is false
this is false but since this was true
this is going to be true okay same thing
the converse inverse they go together to
have the same truth value
okay last example here if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe to the channel I'd love to
have you as a subscriber we've got more
videos like these coming so I want to
help you to boost your score in your
class and make math a little bit easier
to understand but let's talk about this
last example if two lines form right
angles then they are perpendicular
okay the two lines are perpendicular so
first of all sometimes I like to draw a
picture so if two lines
form right angles okay so you can see
the 90-degree angles then the lines are
perpendicular yeah that makes sense
that's true right let's say it backwards
let's say it as a converse statement if
two lines are perpendicular then they
form right angles that's true too right
so what we can do is because it's true
forwards and in reverse meaning the
conditional statement and the converse
statement are both true we can write
this as a by conditional statement by
meaning to conditional meaning it's a
conditional statement at forward and in
reverse so how do we do that let me see
if I can explain this what you do this
is what you want to do is you want to
drop the if okay and you want to replace
the then with this phrase if and only if
so two lines form right angles if and
only if they are perpendicular make
sense so you're dropping the if and
you're replacing two then with if and
only if and what that indicates to
somebody reading that statement is that
all this is true for words and it's true
in Reverse so it doesn't matter if I
interchange the hypothesis and
conclusion it will still be a true
statement so again I hope you're
enjoying these videos subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I look forward to seeing you in some
of the future ones I'll talk to you soon